hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast
choosing the right total organic carbon
analyzer for pharmaceuticals to see
laboratory applications
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab Roos and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
Mavericks and sponsored by Beckman
Coulter Beckman Coulter life sciences
headquartered in Indianapolis Indiana
sets the standard for providing expert
analytical solutions for healthcare
Diagnostics in the biopharmaceutical
industry bio pharmaceutical and
healthcare businesses as well as
academic and government institutions
worldwide rely on Beckman culture life
sciences to deliver the highest quality
data robust analysis and innovative
thinking from classic cutting-edge
Beckman Coulter life sciences has proven
experience and expertise on a wide range
of technology platforms every associate
at Beckman Coulter life sciences is
dedicated to delivering total customer
satisfaction for more information please
visit www.meliar.com/mpanel.htm the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can at
the end of our presentation you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation properly
please let us know and click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems for the green Q&A button
lower-left would now like to introduce
today's speaker Tony Harrison
experienced in water system total
organic carbon conductivity and ozone
analysis and cleanroom monitoring
systems as well as particle
characterization Tony has spent the last
12 years in applied metrology for the
pharmaceutical and helped
manufacturing industries prior to that
he worked for companies providing
process control automation solutions
from manufacturing industry
tony was joint editor on the is PE guide
to ozone sanitation of pharmaceutical
water systems and was also chief editor
of the PHS best practice guide for
cleanroom monitoring
Tony is a well known international
speaker and has provided educational
seminars on TOC liquid particle counting
ozone sanitation for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring in the UK France
Italy India Malaysia China the USA
Scandinavia Ireland hungry Switzerland
Indonesia Belgium Greece Switzerland
Turkey Egypt Denmark and most recently
in Scotland and Poland I will now turn
it over to Tony Harrison for his
presentation
hello and welcome to this presentation
on total organic carbon analysis for the
pharmaceutical industry my name is Tony
Harrison thank you for the introduction
there I am working in the area of
compliance and applications for Beckman
Coulter life sciences today my
presentation will cover a little bit
about the regulations for total organic
carbon in pharmaceutical water I'll also
talk about the typical measurement
technologies which are used and employed
by TOC analyzers used in the
pharmaceutical water analysis quality
control and finally I'll introduce to
you a new technology a new lab TOC
analyzer technology which is in
optimized for pharmaceutical quality
control applications so first let's take
a look a total organic carbon everything
on our planet if it's alive its carbon
based so organic anything organic
contains carbon so
what we're measuring when we're talking
about total organic carbon is the carbon
in the organic molecule it's not a
specific test any organic molecule
contains carbon so this analyzer will be
measuring simply the carbon atoms if you
have a large organic molecule with a lot
of carbon dioxide of carbon atoms in it
then it will reports a large amount of
organic carbon if you have a small
simple organic molecule with a small
number of carbon atoms in there and it
will report a lower amount of organic
carbon so for instance on the screen
here and showing sucrose sucrose has 12
carbon atoms inside it and what we're
measuring is just those carbon atoms
when we're talking about toc-toc is an
important quality characteristic in
pharmaceutical water systems because the
organic content the water can provide a
foodstuff on which microbes can thrive
and of course the last thing we want in
our pharmaceutical water systems is
microbes so controlling the level of
organic carbon is incredibly important
in our water systems so let me just
outline some definitions which will
frame up the conversation today in the
water system there's a total amount of
carbon T C and that total amount of
carbon is made up of a combination of
inorganic carbon such as dissolved
carbon dioxide and of course organic
carbon toç which is what today's talk is
about so the total carbon it's a sum of
the inorganic carbon and the organic
carbon combined together just to put
this in context let me explain about a
parts per billion of t OC so PPD
normally is what we measure and report
organic car
in pharmaceutical water and ppb is
parts-per-billion in the dissolved phase
or in a liquid a PPV indicates weight or
mass in a gas phase ppb is volume but in
these old phase can be B is mass or rate
so one part per billion of total organic
carbon in one liter of very pure water
is in fact one microgram so we're
measuring very small trace amounts here
and measuring one microgram accurately
in one liter of water which weighs a
kilo that's like having a wristwatch
which is accurate to measuring one
second in 32 years so effectively we
were measuring almost trace amounts
almost zero when we're measuring par
civilian of total organic carbon now
there are some changes happening in the
European pharmacopoeia for
pharmaceutical water it's a slow process
but there are some changes coming
currently it texts from the European
pharmacopoeia states that water for
injection should be made from a
distillation process so it actually says
water injection from distillation so
it's quite specific
that's how water for injection is made
but of course water is one of the
largest raw materials used in the
pharmaceutical and biopharmaceutical
industries thousands of gallons are used
every day so making water injection from
the distillation process is a very
energy intensive and very costly process
so it's certainly here in Europe
companies like Novartis and Roche have
been working with the European
pharmacopoeia to ask them if they could
use a third type of water quality called
highly purified water it actually has
the same quality attributes as water for
injection
it's made by instead of a distillation
process it's made by a double pass
reverse osmosis process the microbial
control for the ward system is achieved
through dissolving ozone into the water
and ozone gives a very high level of
microbial control so unique to the
European pharmacopoeia
this is the third type of water highly
purified water and the reason these
companies like Novartis and Roche
persuaded the regulators to allow this
third type of water is because reverse
osmosis is a uses a greatly reduced
amount of energy and therefore the cost
to manufacture this quality of water is
much lower these companies also worked
with the European pharmacopoeia and to
demonstrate to them that the microbe
biological control of water systems cold
water in better in fact a certainly
equal to heat sanitized water systems as
as mentioned a moment ago in the
introduction there is a guide available
from the International Society of
pharmaceutical engineering is PE and
it's a good practice guide for ozone
sanitization of pharmaceutical water
systems this guide was created by an
international group including myself
there as you can see I was one of the
core team leaders together with one of
the senior engineers on a from the
global team at Pfizer but you can see
contributors for this document also came
from Novartis schering-plough
when schering-plough existed
GlaxoSmithKline and Sanofi so we entered
and engaged with all of these senior
level engineers from these different
companies to combine and pull the
knowledge to provide the best practice
and the reason we did that was to
convince the regulators it's the tombow
door pass reverse osmosis and ozone for
microbiological control gives an
excellent quality of water which in many
cases is better than heat sanitized
water for injection so the European
pharmacopoeia is going through a
consultation process right now to
consider the use of double pass RO
reverse osmosis as an allowable
technology for the manufacture of water
for injection so the European
Directorate who own the European
pharmacopoeia
here you can see they've got an expert
workshop in practice at the moment which
is working on the use of reverse osmosis
for water injection
one of the criteria that they attach to
the use of the will pass reverse osmosis
is that the COC limits for the water may
towards for injection manufactured using
double class RO should be lowered so
currently the limit allowable in
purified water and water for injection
however it's made is 500 parts per
billion of TLC however as I mentioned at
the start of this talk TOC is
effectively an organic food for any
microbes that might find themselves in
the water system so what the European
pharmacopoeia is asking is that if they
allow the use of double pass reverse
osmosis as a method for making water for
injection they're suggesting that in
their document here a significant
reduction of the TOC level will be
required because they are saying that's
then a lot safer than a higher 500 ppb
limit if you lower that TOC limit and if
any microbes do manage to get into the
water system they've got no food to eat
so it's likely that we'll see in the
future a lowering of that TOC limits for
water for injections from 500 ppb to a
lowering lower
level this processes at very early
stages at the moment so I think we're a
few years off but potentially the
expectations for wards occur injection
in the European pharmacopoeia will lower
in the future okay so that's just some
industry news for you a heads up if you
like so let's take a look at common
total organic carbon analyzer
technologies now TOC measurement is used
on many different types of water right
from industrial wastewater which can
have thousands as parts to a million of
TOC in it right down to water for
injection and highly purified water
there's a mistake on this slide by the
way it says highly purified water
I mean ultra pure water there on the
right hand of the screen that says
highly purified it should take ultra
pure ultra pure is the water used in the
semiconductor industry for manufacturing
their wafers semiconductor wafers and
you can see that the target level of toc
they look for any semiconductor ultra
pure waters is less than 0.1 ppb so
these water qualities are extremely high
used in the semiconductor industry much
purer than we use in the pharmaceutical
and biopharmaceutical industry so TOC
analysis is used as a quality attribute
measurement right across this range of
water qualities the industrial
wastewater were the thousands of parts
per million of TOC presence it's quite
difficult to oxidize there's a lot of
organic material in that water and to
oxidize it we need a very aggressive
analysis on the other hand the purified
water water for injection and ultra poor
pure waters very easy to oxidize is
relatively low levels of organic
material present and the oxidization
technology does not need to be as
aggressive as it does for industrial
wastewater so it's quite common for TOC
analyzers measuring TOC in industrial
wastewater or river waters or effluent
waters to use a very aggressive
high-temperature oven combustion system
which incinerates the water sample
sample at high temperatures and then any
organic carbon that's present in the
water turned into carbon dioxide and
it's measured using non-dispersive
infrared that's a very aggressive
oxidation technology in this middle
group of waters including our purified
water and water for injection for
pharmaceutical use there's two common
technologies used in here a combination
of ultraviolet light and persulfate
which is quite a wide range of analysis
and a differential conductivity using
ultraviolet light so these are very
common technologies used in the lower
toç waters typically the
high-temperature oven TOC analyzers
require a lot of maintenance in some
cases where the water is very dirty they
can require maintenance on a weekly
basis whereas down in the very pure
waters the purified water and water
injection the simpler technology
employed in these TOC analyzers for this
type of water quality typically much
lower maintenance so let's take a look
at the technology for high-temperature
ovens
typically the organic carbon is drawn
into an oven which may have a
temperature in excess of 850 degrees
centigrade it's very high temperature
the sample is oxidized as it's
incinerated and any organic carbons
present in that sample is turned into
carbon dioxide gas this gas is then
measured using it a non-dispersive
infrared sensor this sensor uses an
infrared light
infrared is absorbed by carbon dioxide
so the more carbon dioxide present the
lower the amount of infrared reaches the
detector so it's quite a simple
measurement
unfortunately for pharmaceutical
applications this type of analysis has
quite a large amount of measurement
uncertainties so it's a very low-level
toc waters it's not really suitable
typically this type of technology has a
limited quantitation in the range of
between 50 and 150 ppb and of course
most modern pharmaceutical water systems
using high technology for water
treatment achieving toc levels much
lower than 50 ppb so this high
temperature oven is not really suitable
for measuring purified water and water
for injection certainly not in the
future when the European pharmacopoeia
changes the rules and we have to get
much lower than 500 ppb in fact I was
speaking to a user of a high-temperature
oven technology fairly recently in the
pharmaceutical industry and they
reported back that after 8 months of
working with the TOC analyzer the TOC
analyzers failed the system suitability
test and they've never managed to get it
to pass since and those of you who are
familiar with the requirements in the
folic apears system suitability testing
is one of the required tests that you
must pass for a TOC analyzer to be used
for pharmaceutical quality water as I
mentioned at the start of this talk
TOC analysis is not a specific test
measures anything organic and it reports
it in the same way so it doesn't tell
you what type of organic materials you
have in your water system so the
generally speaking most of the phonic
appears across the world with the
exception of the Japanese far look
appear require you to do a system
suitability test using a
difficult to oxidize organic material
and then easy to oxidize organic
material so typically the test is done
with a benzoquinone which is considered
relatively difficult to oxidize and the
sample of benzoquinone contains 500
parts per billion of carbon and then
also a test is run on the analyzer is
challenged with sucrose containing
equally 500 ppb of carbon and the TOC
analyzer must analyze the difficult
oxidized and easy to oxidize samples and
give results within plus or minus 15%
and this is defined by the pharmacopoeia
now the issue as I mentioned with the
high-temperature oven TOC analyzers is
at these very low levels around 500 ppb
or less the results can vary quite a lot
they're really designed for measuring
hundreds of thousands of ppm so down
here in the PPD levels the measurement
uncertainties don't give a very good
reproducibility of results so here you
can see on the Left we're testing
sucrose and benzoquinone and the results
vary quite a lot so the average from the
sucrose there from these measurements is
around 408 ppb the three measurements
from the benzoquinone is around 544 ppb
so the ability of the analyzer to
accurately report is the issue here it's
perfectly capable of oxidizing both of
these materials but the measurement
inaccuracies mean that in this
particular case the difference between
the reported results were 33% so in this
case the TOC on either although it's
perfectly capable of analyzing a wide
range of THC as organic material in this
case it failed for system suitability
test so high-temperature ovens not
really a good technology for us to use
in our pharmaceutical water analysis
so very good for very dirty waters
wastewater etc but not so good for
pharmaceutical water so let's take a
look at another technology here a dual
cell differential conductivity TOC
analyzer here's a couple of examples of
dual cell TOC analyzers the one on the
right is using UV lights as the oxidizer
combined with an oxidizing chemical
sulfate and an acid and this combination
of these chemicals and the UV light uses
quite a wide range of TOC analysis the
one on the left is designed to sit on
line on a pharmaceutical purified water
or water for injection loop where we
know that the TOC levels going to be a
lot lower so it doesn't use the
chemicals it just uses a UV light which
is perfectly adequate for this
application
most of these analyzers rely on the fact
that when carbon dioxide is dissolved
into water it makes a very weak acid
carbonic acid and this carbonic acid can
contribute to the conductivity of the
water so by measuring the conductivity
and oxidizing the organics to carbon
dioxide that carbon dioxide then
dissolves in the water and raises the
conductivity so measuring differential
conductivity allows us to measure the
carbon dioxide from the oxidized
organics so that's how we'll look how
these technologies work this one's here
it doesn't have the reagent the
oxidizing reagent or the acid so this is
the online version at the top the water
flows into a small reservoir and then
continuously goes to drain and at the
bottom of the picture here you can see a
pump so this pump draws a sample at a
continuous flow rate from the reservoir
at the top by working in this way the
TOC analyzer is able to control the flow
rate of the water through the analyzer
this is very important because the water
will now flow through the analyzer and
take two separate paths on the left it
passes past eight ultraviolet light and
that ultraviolet light oxidizes the
organic material as it goes past so
controlling the flow rate is very
important because we want consistent
exposure to the UV lamp and that's why
it uses a pump to draw the water from
the reservoir at the top you can see
there are two flow paths through this
analyzer on the right there's a delayed
coil which means that the water on the
Left passing by the UV lamp and the
water on the right without a UV lamp
with a delayed coil both of those waters
reach the analysis cells at the same
time so what we have here is two
analysis cells there's a membrane
separating these analysis cells from the
water system and this wall this membrane
is permeable for carbon dioxide only so
these membranes keep any interfering
substances which may be present in the
water away from the measurement cells so
the carbon dioxide from the organic and
the inorganic passes through and is
measured by temperature compensated
conductivity cells two separate
measurements now it can be and some of
you using this technology may have seen
this but it can be the TOC calculated by
these measurements it suffers from
interferences from inorganic carbon in
the water so on the right here there's
no UV lamp so what we're measuring is
carbon dioxide from any inorganic carbon
carbon dioxide dissolved in the water on
the right hand side on the right hand
side we measure inorganic
on the left hand side we've got that
inorganic carbon or in the water and
we've also used the UV lamp to oxidize
any organic carbon to carbon dioxide so
on the left hand side we have the
inorganic and the organic carbon so
we're actually measuring total carbon on
the left hand side and total inorganic
carbon on the right hand side the
analyzer uses these two measurements to
calculate the level of POC present in
the water now the issue with
pharmaceutical grade waters is typically
the starting points for these is reverse
osmosis and reverse of mostly tends to
remove most of the contaminants from the
water that carbon dioxide will pass
straight through the reverse osmosis
system and so you tend to find that
carbon dioxide present in the water is
concentrated when passes into the
purified water so the relative levels of
carbon dioxide forming the inorganic
carbon is quite high typically on a
pharmaceutical water system when
compared to the levels of organic carbon
so we're measuring inorganic and total
and calculating TOC it can give some
challenges for the for the measurement
as I mentioned total organic carbon TC
is the sum of inorganic and organic
carbon so if you measure total carbon
and you measure total inorganic carbon
you can make a calculation to estimate
the amount of TOC in the water system
now I'm going to work through a brief
example here to explain some of the
challenges you might face using this
technology so we're going to calculate
the TOC we're measuring the total carbon
which in this example is 2000 ppb and
most of that total carbon as I mentioned
is made up of the carbon dioxide
concentrated into the water through the
reverse osmosis process so one
thousand 900 ppb of that total carbon is
made up of inorganic carbon dissolved
carbon dioxide so the actual level of
total organic carbon is only 100 ppb now
as I mentioned on the right we're
measuring inorganic carbon on the Left
we're measuring total carbon and we're
making a calculation to estimate toç now
this technology has relatively low
measurement errors but if we sum them
all up like variations in the flow rate
variations in the UV intensity over time
variations in the permeability of those
membranes which are allowing the carbon
dioxide gas to go through to the
measurement cells and also slight drift
in those temperature compensated
conductivity cells all of these
measurement errors typically add up to a
measurement error of plus or minus 2%
for those two measurement cells and it
doesn't sound very much what's the minus
2% sounds quite reasonably accurate but
as I mentioned we're calculating the toc
here we're measuring a total carbon and
we're measuring total inorganic carbon
and we're making the calculation so back
to our example where we have total
carbon of around 2000 ppb most of which
is inorganic carbon 1,900 ppb so we're
looking to measure and report around 100
ppb
for the TLC however I've just said the
measurement sensors have an accuracy of
plus or minus 2% so the t-totally in
organic carbon can measure with the plus
or minus 2% anywhere between 1862 ppb to
1968 ppb and similarly the total carbon
with its plus or minus 2% could measure
anywhere between 1960 to 2040 ppb
so if we do the maths you can see that
the calculated and reported toc can be
anywhere in the range from between 22
ppb to 178 ppb so here you can see one
of the main challenges for using this
technology for measuring pharmaceutical
quality waters in the sense that it's
not doing a direct measurement it's
doing a measurement of inorganic and
total carbon and it's actually making a
calculation now for any of you which
have used this technology in your
quality control laboratory for measuring
pharmaceutical waters may have
occasionally seen this technology
reporting li- TOC readings and the
reason for that is that there's a slight
drift between those two measurement
cells as they drift over time between
the two of them that drift applies an
offset to the measurement so over time
the measurement can actually have an
offset which forces it to reproduce and
reports a negative TOC so particularly
for very very pure waters with low
levels of TOC low levels of organic
carbon this technology can periodically
report negative TOC and the reason for
that is because it's a calculated TOC
measurement this is a another example of
a dual conductivity sense of TOC
analyzer this case is a flow through
analyzer so it is a conductivity sensor
on the left and there's a conductivity
sensor on the right the water flows from
left to right the initial conductivity
sensor is measuring the carbon dioxide
from the inorganic carbon there's a UV
lamp in the middle here and the at the
end we're measuring the total carbon
from the oxidized carbon and the
inorganic carbon so this does the same
thing as the other technology it
measures total power
and total inorganic carbon and it does a
calculation the other thing to bear in
mind with this technology is the flow
path through the analyzer is quite short
it's about three minutes total time so
the it's unlikely that higher levels of
toc will be completely oxidized in that
time not enough time for the UV lamp to
do complete oxidation the pharmacopoeia
at the european pharmacopoeia in the
chapter on toc analysis it mentions the
objective of these toc analyzers is to
completely oxidize the organic molecules
to carbon dioxide and the reason it
makes this requirement is because as the
organic molecules are oxidized down to
carbon dioxide as the bonds are being
broken down right often the intermediate
species before it fully goes to carbon
dioxide can be organic acids these
organic acids can contribute quite
strongly to the conductivity so you get
a conductivity profile like I'm showing
on the screen here where the
intermediate acids actually give a
higher conductivity and the final we
classic the carbonic acid from the
carbon dioxide so with a longer chain
molecule quite often you get these
intermediate species which give a higher
conductivity so a complete toc oxidation
to carbon dioxide is very important so
particular you can see a small chain
molecule methanol here it goes straight
almost straight to carbon dioxide so the
oxidation profile is very different so
why they important well typically most
people calibrate TOC analyzers using 500
parts per billion carbon contained in
sucrose it's a very simple calibration
standard to make so sucrose containing
500 ppb of carbon so if we put that
through this TOC and I keep an eye to
see as I mentioned a 3 minute flow path
as it goes past the UV lamp it's
partially oxidized and then it measures
the car conductivity so we've just told
this online that we're putting through
500 ppb of carbon so it measures the
conductivity and says okay I now know
three points for equal to 500 parts per
billion on the conductivity scale of
carbon now if this sees a simpler to
oxidize organic still containing the
same amount of organic carbon 500 ppb in
this particular case that's three
minutes flow past is fine complete
oxidation occurs no problem at all
and now however the conductivity is
measuring for that 500 ppb of carbon is
much lower so it reports a much lower
level of organic carbon grow in fact the
same amount present this is a paper
published on available for download from
the internet by a company called GE
severs and they were challenging
different types of measurement
technology for TOC with different types
of organic material you can see here in
this excerpt from this that they applied
500 parts per billion of carbon in
sucrose through these different models
manufacturers of TOC analyzer
they've all been calibrated with sucrose
containing 500 ppb
of carbon so not surprisingly they all
report fairly good results and
comparable results when challenged with
sucrose containing 500 ppb of carbon
however if you apply 500 ppb of carbon
in a very simple to oxidize substance
like methanol you can see here where
that that TOC analyzer using the three
minutes low path will under report it
could exceed less conductivity than it
did with the sucrose and so it reports a
lower level of TOC so I'd like to
introduce to you now and you laboratory
TOC analyzer technology
so we've looked at high-temperature oven
we've looked at differential
conductivity this analysis method uses a
combination of ultraviolet light and for
sulphate the persulfate is a an
oxidizing reagent and it measures the
final oxidized carbon dioxide as a gas
using a non-dispersive infrared sensor
this analyzer is actually manufactured
by the makers of the ANATEL online TOC
analyzers who've been making these
online TOC analyzers for over 20 years
so when designing this TOC analyzer the
rules we were looking for that it should
be a direct TOC measurement we didn't
want any calculated TOC here because of
the reasons we mentioned particularly in
the light that European farmers may
reduce the target level for TOC in the
organic vapor so in the water purify the
water for injection to lower than 500
ppb so we didn't want to make any
calculated TOC estimates here we wanted
a direct measurement of POC typically
these TOC analyzers are very busy in the
quality control laboratory so we
designed it to help improve productivity
most users of TOC analyzers in the
quality control laboratory takes 4
samples and discard the first sample the
reason is that they know full well that
first sample will contain some carryover
from the previous file so with this
design we've designed it so it
eliminates pretty much carryover from
file to file and allows you to take a
much lower number of samples to get your
TOC results and the last thing we've
done here is we were conscious that the
pharmaceutical industry is going through
a challenging time and are seeking to
reduce costs of ownership so we've
reduced the service costs for this TOC
Anna
it's a very simple device and the only
needs an annual service versus our more
typical six monthly service requirements
for most other technologies so let me
explain how it is the direct TOC
measurement the analysis as I mentioned
uses a UV lamp and a reagent uses an
oxidizing reagent and an acid as well
and there's a carrier gas here and all
these are put into the sample analysis
cell here the UV reactor the inorganic
carbon and the organic carbon are
independently turned into carbon dioxide
have removed there's a Peltier cool to
remove any moisture and then it passes
through a non-dispersive infrared
detector and then finally goes through a
catalytic ozone destructor because you
realize generate ozone so there's a
catalytic destructive air to remove the
ozone the first step in the analysis is
to remove the inorganic carbon from the
sample so we add an acid to the water
sample we've just taken into the
analysis chamber and this as it shifts
the pH of the water to less than pH 2 so
it's quite acidified and then this
acidified state the carbon dioxide tends
to come out of solution out of carbonic
acid it moves out into carbon dioxide
gas and then what we do is we use the
carrier gas which would typically a pure
nitrogen gas to bubble through the
sample and push the carbon dioxide out
of the sample and into the infrared
detector so the infrared detector
measures the carbon dioxide from the air
in organic and you can see from the
graph here we wait until the all of the
carbon dioxide is removed all being
organics is removed before we start the
optimization process so leave the
organic carbon so we take the sample
into the UV reactor where the analysis
takes place we add the acid the acid
pushes the
organic carbon out of solution as a
carbon dioxide gas and then we use the
sparging ask the nitrogen gas to push
that carbon dioxide out from the water
sample and into the infrared detector
the infrared detector measures the
carbon dioxide and it waits till it sees
all of the carbon dioxide from the
inorganic is removed before it reports
to the analyzer it's safe to go ahead
and measure the toc so we completely
removed the t IC from the sample and we
wait before the detector tells us all of
the carbon dioxide is removed before we
turn the UV lamp on and start the
oxidization of the organic carbon so
direct measurements of toc is done with
two processes first of all we turn the
UV lamp on the UV lamp acts on the water
molecules the h2o and turns them into
our h+ radicals which are quite strong
oxidizers so they begin to work on the
organic bonds at the same time the UV
lamp activates for the sulfates and now
that the sulphate molecules are also
strong oxidizers so the combination of
the UV lamp and the activated
persulphate has a very strong oxidation
on the organic materials so now we're
going to measure
to measure the carbon dioxide directly
from TOC so in this particular case we
turned the UV lamp on once we've made
sure all the inorganic materials removed
we turn the UV lamp on and now the UV
light
combined with the sulphate is starting
to oxidize the organic material to
carbon dioxide so then we use the
carrier gas to push the carbon dioxide
from the TOC back out and into the
infrared detector here and now we can
measure directly the carbon dioxide just
from the TOC so as I mentioned we wait
until the carbon dioxide from the
inorganic is completely removed before
we turn the UV lamp on and our direct
measurements of the carbon dioxide from
the TOC
as I mentioned we've tried to improve
the productivity of the way these
analyzers worked many users of TOC
analyzers were complaining that they had
to take four samples from each vial and
discard the first sample so we've
already carry over from the previous
vial so you can see here on the Left
this would be ideal
where vial a the two samples from vial a
does not cross over into the two samples
from vial B but more typically the
picture on the right here is the more
typical picture where the first sample
analyzed from vial B is in fact a
combination of the carbon from the
previous valve our a and the new viral
variety and this is quite common and for
this reason typically people do four
analyses and ignore the first one to get
past this sample to sample carry over so
what we've done with this analyzer is
very simple processes three steps first
of all between vials we back flush the
sample line using the reagents in the
analyzer itself so the sample line is
back flushed and that is taken to drain
the second step
we make it a forward flow so we take a
small amount of the water from the next
vial and we flush that through the
analyzer and again it goes to drain and
the final step we take is a third sample
now this one is the sample taken for
analysis so we've reduced the number of
samples you need to take typically they
carry over from sample to sample using
this technique is reduced to less than
0.2% carry over so we can take just
three samples to get the analysis
instead of four and of course it will
take me one less sample instead of the
four samples we can improve productivity
by up to 25% the other feedback we got
was that some of the other technologies
used for TOC analysis using reagents or
carrier gas they don't measure the
reagent or the carrier gas and if this
runs out halfway through a tray of
samples the analyzer just carries on
doing the analysis regardless and
reporting incorrect results with the end
result that the user has to repeat the
entire tray of samples again and
typically a tray of samples in a TOC
analyzer with say 64 samples it can take
up to 20 hours to do so it takes a whole
day to do the tests again so what we've
done with this new design is we reduced
the servicing costs we spread it out to
a 12 monthly service interval and the
way we do that is by having a very
simple design where monitors every
critical parameter in the analysis so it
monitors the carrier gas the UV lamp
intensity is measured the flow rate of
the example the non-dispersive infrared
detector the pump and the reagents are
all measured and monitored so any point
during the analysis any of those
critical parameters goes wrong instantly
the analyzer stops doing the analysis
and puts a warning sign on the screen so
you're not wasting that entire tray full
of water samples and getting incorrect
results
so I finished my presentation today I
believe there may have been some
questions so any questions yes thank you
Tony for that informative presentation
before we get started in the question
and answer session I'd like to remind
our audience how to submit their
questions they can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green and a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many of them as we can we do have one
question already does calibration or
adjustment for metrology nomenclature
not account for any instrument drift on
any analytical instrument okay so that's
a tricky question to answer because it's
actually a trick question
calibration according to the ISO
standards is in fact a comparison of the
measurements of the analyzer against a
certified standard so it's just a check
to make sure that the analyzer is in
fact measuring correctly now a common
misinterpretation of calibration is in
fact calibration adjustments where we
challenge the analyzer with multiple
certified standards calibration
standards the analyzer then adjusts its
measurements to make sure that it is
reporting correctly so if you did that
if you did a periodic adjustment of the
calibration to make sure that the TOC
analyzer is reporting correctly then
that would indeed get round the problem
of those two sense of measuring
independently so a more frequent
calibration adjustment gets around that
problem with the two sensors in the dual
conductivity sensor TOC analyzer so it's
a correct the only downside to that of
course is you're having to do a more
frequent calibration of the analyzer and
this can be quite time-consuming so
thank you for that question
thank you we do have another one
ro typically has hi I see as you have
explained the reagent list instrument is
I'm sorry I'm reading the wrong question
I apologize for the QbD 1200 perching
the sample that is not measuring NPO see
what happens to any volatiles are they
lost if yes then NPRC
is not equal to toc correct yes for sure
it's very unusual really to have virtual
organics in pharmaceutical grade water
systems they're more commonly found in
drinking waters and more to river waters
and things like that
typically it's very low levels of
purgable organics are found in
pharmaceutical quality waters so it's
not really relevant to the measurements
we're talking about here but yes it is
quite correct if there was purgable
organic carbon in the sample then that
would be lost by the process that the
QED used so if you are using it for
instance to measure drinking water and
wastewater applications and the purgable
organic elements of the toc would be
lost using this type of technology and
as I mentioned this one is specifically
designed for use or optimized for you
should I say in the pharmaceutical
quality waters where purging organic
carbon is typically almost non-existent
so it's not an issue for this particular
application but you're quite correct if
you had a dirty water sample with lots
of purgable organic carbon in it then
this technology would not measure the
total organic carbon very accurately but
for pharmaceutical water qualities it's
it's fun thank you and you have another
question our audience member asks we
have been using qvd 1200 analyzer for
manual single sample measurements
samples are
in triplicate however the first
measurement had to be discarded because
it would blow the known
parts-per-billion of the prepared 100
parts per billion standard is that
normal okay so yes you can use the QbD
1200 for taking manual samples from a
beaker instead of with the autosampler
the downside of doing it that way is
that you lose the sample to sample carry
over elimination technique to this back
flushing and forward flushing now
describe that process only works with
the auto sampler so if you are using it
it's not really designed for that you
can use it to take a manual grab sample
from a beater and you lose that sample
to sample carry over elimination so
unfortunately it's likely that the first
sample you take will not have as
accurate toc in it as it would do it if
you were using the auto sampler so thank
you for that question
great and we do have another one
how long in minutes does the QbD take to
process the three replicates described
in the presentation yes that's a good
question and as I was at pains to point
out in the presentation here the length
of analysis depends entirely on the
amount of inorganic and organic carbon
its presence in the sample because the
analyzer firstly waits until all of the
carbon dioxide from the inorganic carbon
is removed and of course if there's a
large amounts of inorganic carbon that
will take longer than if there's a small
amount the same for the toc analysis a
TOC analysis again the time it takes all
vary according to the amounts of organic
carbon in the water sample but what we
found is that this TOC analyzer is
typically will a now an Alaia three
samples and anywhere on pharmaceutical
quality waters between 6 and 10
minutes and comparing that to other
technologies that I've described here
quite often they take a longer time than
that to do this analysis so thank you
for that question
thank you we have another question how
does the QbD 1200 behave with methanol
compared to glucose okay so because
we're making a direct toc measurement
here we're actually measuring the carbon
dioxide from the carbon atoms as they're
oxidized in the organic type of but it's
a complex chain of upside more complex
chain like the sucrose or the methanol
is a more simple confident change that
doesn't really interfere with the signal
at all because we oxidize the carbon to
carbon dioxide and we measure it as a
carbon dioxide gas so we're not using
conductivity here which is the problem I
described earlier where we are used if
we use dual conductivity sensors to
measure the change in conductivity from
the organic carbon as its oxidizing the
water then the fact that the sucrose is
more takes a longer time to oxidize can
actually interfere with the results
you've got there so an analyzer
calibrated with sucrose using dual
conductivity cells would read report 500
ppb of carbon in methanol as a much
lower level but with the QbD 1200
because we are oxidizing the the organic
carbon to carbon dioxide gas and not
using differential conductivity then it
didn't have any impact only if you ve
1200 so thank you for that question
thank you Tony I think we have no more
questions I would once again like to
thank our presenter Tony Harrison for
his participation in today's webcast and
did you have any final comments for our
audience no just to thank everybody for
taking the time to listen to me today I
hope it's been informative and
useful presentation thank you very much
indeed Dana for so Brenda for having
introduced me today thank you
you're very welcome I would also like to
thank our sponsors Beckman culture life
sciences for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April 2016 you'll receive an email from
labyrinth learning you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all we have
for today see you next time goodbye